KIKO: My name is Kiko.
I'm part of the music team
here at Google YouTube.
And I'm excited
to be here today.
We have a special guest
for you guys today,
a gentleman by the
name of Sparsh who
has inspired so many throughout
the world through his music
as well as his philanthropic
work with cancer research
and children with disabilities
and earthquake victims, et
cetera.
And he's going to
perform for us today.
So without further ado, Sparsh.
SPARSH SHAH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[MUSIC - "LOSE YOURSELF"]
SPARSH SHAH: (SINGING) Ah.
Ah.
(RAPPING) Look, if you had
one shot or one opportunity
to seize everything you
ever wanted, one moment,
would you capture it,
or just let it slip?
Yo.
His palms are sweaty,
knees weak, arms are heavy.
There's vomit on his sweater
already, Mom's spaghetti.
He's nervous.
But on the surface, he looks
calm and ready to drop bombs
but he keeps on forgetting
what he wrote down.
The whole crowd goes so loud.
He opens his mouth, but
the words won't come out.
And he's choking out.
Everybody's joking now.
The clock's run out.
Time's up, over-- blaow!
Snap back to reality.
Oh, there goes gravity.
Oh, there goes
Rabbit, he choked.
He's so mad, but he
won't give up that easy.
No, he won't have it,
he knows, his whole
back's to these ropes.
It don't matter, he's dope.
He knows that, but he's broke.
He's so stagnant, he
knows when he goes back
to his mobile home, that's when
it's back to the lab again, yo!
This whole rhapsody better
go capture this moment
and hope it don't pass him.
You better lose yourself in the
music, the moment, you own it.
You better never let it go.
Come on!
You only get one shot.
Do not miss your chance to blow.
Because opportunity
comes once in a lifetime.
You better lose yourself
in the music, the moment.
You own it.
You better never let it go.
You only get one shot.
Do not miss your chance
to blow this opportunity
comes once in a lifetime, yo.
His soul's escaping through
this hole that is gaping.
This world is mine
for the taking.
Make me king as we move
toward a New World Order,
a normal life is boring.
But superstardom's
close to post-mortem.
It only goes harder.
Homie grows hotter.
He blows.
It's all over.
These haters all on him,
coast-to-coast shows.
He's known as the Globetrotter,
lonely roads God only knows.
He's grown farther from home.
He's no brother.
He goes home and barely
knows his little brother.
But hold your nose 'cause
here goes the cold water.
His homies don't
want him no more.
He's cold product.
They moved on to the
next schmoe who flows.
He nose-dove and sold nada.
So the soap opera is told.
It unfolds, I suppose
it's old, partner.
But the beat goes on.
Da da dom da dom.
You better lose
yourself in the music.
The moment, you own it.
You better never let it go.
You only get one shot.
Do not miss your chance to blow.
This opportunity comes
ones in a lifetime.
You better lose yourself
in the music, the moment.
You own it.
You better never let it go.
You only get one shot.
Do not miss your chance to blow.
This opportunity comes
once in a lifetime, yo!
No more games.
I'm gonna change
what you call rage.
Tear this entire roof
off like a T rex caged.
I was playing in the beginning.
The mood all changed.
I'm been chewed up and spit
out and booed offstage.
But I kept rhyming and stepped
right in the next cypher.
Best believe somebody's
paying the Pied Piper.
All the pain inside
amplified by the fact
that I can't get by
with my nine-to-five
and I can't provide the right
type of life for my family,
'cause man, these underpaid
food stamps don't buy diapers.
And there's no movie,
there's no Mekhi Phifer.
This is my life and
these times are so hard.
But it's getting even harder
trying to feed and water
my seed, plus teeter-totter.
Caught up between being a
brother and a prima donna.
Baby mama drama screaming
on her, too much for me
to wanna stay in one spot.
Another day of
monotony's gotten me
to the point I'm like a snail.
I've got to formulate a plot
or end up in jail or shot.
Success is the only
option I have left.
Failure's not.
Mom, I love you, but
this trailer's got to go.
I cannot grow old
in Salem's Lot.
So here I go.
It's my shot.
Wheels fail me not.
This may be the only
opportunity that I got.
You'd better lose
yourself in the music.
The moment you own it, you
better never let it go.
You only get one shot.
Do not miss your chance to blow.
If you know the lyrics, sing!
Come on!
You better lose
yourself in the music.
The moment, you own it.
You better never let it go.
You only get one shot.
Do not miss your chance to blow.
This opportunity comes
once in a lifetime.
Yo!
[CHEERING]
SPARSH SHAH: (SPEAKING)
You can do anything
you set your mind to, man.
Keep talking.
It's not over yet, ready?
Now comes the fun part.
[HUMMING]
Get rhythm!
[CHEERING]
SPARSH SHAH: Thank you so much.
KIKO: Everybody give it
up for him once again.
[CHEERING]
SPARSH SHAH: Thank
you so much Is there
a way to turn this off?
So that, oh, OK.
It's off.
Well, you Googlers
are always one--
at least a few steps ahead.
It's always what my dad told
me when we used to play chess.
Like, always think a
couple of steps ahead.
You guys are way ahead.
[LAUGHTER]
KIKO: Well, first.
I just want to thank you
for joining us today.
SPARSH SHAH: Thank you so
much for having me here.
It's amazing.
KIKO: Absolutely.
So I guess my first
question is, I guess, when,
and how old were
you when you first
realized your love for music?
SPARSH SHAH: The great
thing about that is--
for me, music, it's
been with me all along.
I mean, it's not like
I grew into music.
Music grew with me.
Like, it's the deepest
part of my soul.
It's like we were two
childhood friends that
grew up in the same neighborhood
and we always knew each other.
And I was exposed to music
ever since I was little.
So that's the great thing,
because I got to learn.
I would hum every song that
my family played in the car.
I would start singing.
Ultimately, I started
correcting my parents.
It was crazy.
I started with piano actually.
I broke my arms a
lot, broke my legs
a lot because of my condition.
But that really-- my mom
told me that no matter
how many bones you
broke in you life,
your voice would never break.
So I realized, you
know, yeah, I may
be here with 130
fractures in my life now.
I had 40 coming out of the womb.
But my vocal cords, like,
my voice never broke.
So that's basically why I became
a singer and not necessarily
an instrumental musician.
That's, like, my main focus.
KIKO: That's good advice, mom.
The voice will never break.
So thank you for that.
My next question is, just you
touched on some of the things
you've endured health wise.
So I guess my question is how
did you keep your motivation up
to do some of the
things that you've
been doing, sort of
regardless of everything else.
SPARSH SHAH: For me, my
motivation comes from--
I mean, really, it
comes from everybody.
So you all here, I'm
just letting you know,
you are my motivation.
And I really mean that by
the heart when I say it.
So thank you.
Thank you for that.
[APPLAUSE]
So that's the thing.
Like, for me, it comes
from three places,
my fans, my friends
and my family, and God.
I mean, my fans, they've been
my global support system.
They've been with me everywhere
through my musical journey.
And I've been able to
help them out, too.
So it's not just
them supporting me.
It's me supporting them with
my music and my message.
I've been so blessed to have
inspired so many people,
and show them, you
know, it doesn't
matter what you go through.
It matters what
you want to get to.
And doing that is great
for me and for my fans,
like for me to tell my
fans that and for them
to get that message.
It's great.
My friends and my family,
I mean, obviously, my fans
are my biggest support system.
But my family is like my
longest running support system.
They knew me since I was born.
So they've always--
without them, I
would not have
been gently raised
to be the child I am today.
And the values that they gave
me, they imbibed into me.
It was, oh, my god, it was cra--
the values that they gave me,
without that I wouldn't have
been the strong, resilient
teenager that I am today
and I definitely wouldn't
have gone out to the world
and showcased my talent.
And most importantly, I
believe my greatest strength
comes from God.
He's there with
me wherever I go,
wherever I am, and
no matter what.
And you know,
every day I wake up
and I always thank God for
giving me another day of life.
Because number one, he could
easily take it away from me.
Every breath, I believe every
breath we take is by his grace.
Me coming out with 40
fractures in the womb--
I mean, I know, you're
probably thinking
what is this kid talking about
with all these fractures?
I have osteogenesis imperfecta,
which is brittle bones disease
in layman's terms.
And I've suffered many
fractures through my life,
many surgeries.
And with those 40 fractures,
some of the biggest
surgeries I've gone through--
I had a spinal fusion in August.
All that, I honestly think
that without God's grace,
I wouldn't have been here today.
So I always thank him for
giving me another day.
Because he could have taken
it away from me in an instant.
He could take over for me
right now if he wanted to.
But the fact that he didn't
and he's letting me live
is just saying your
fight's not over, son.
You're going to fight for me.
I know you're going
to fight for me.
So that's why I
wake up every day.
And I think if we
all open our eyes
and live like that, that's the
greatest sense of purpose we
could ever have in
our life, period.
KIKO: Amen.
SPARSH SHAH: Woo!
[APPLAUSE]
KIKO: So in just knowing
part of your story,
there's been a lot of high
points that I read through.
But what do you
feel like has been
your best or happiest
moment so far in the journey
that you've been on.
SPARSH SHAH: Wow.
That's crazy.
Definitely Google is one
of my happiest moments.
KIKO: Thank you.
SPARSH SHAH: Of course.
Yeah.
I mean I've had a
lot of performances.
That's the thing.
I don't let my biggest
performance define my success.
I'm not the kind
of guy that says,
yo, you know, I performed
at Madison Square Garden,
UN headquarters, Google,
Deloitte, all the stuff.
Yeah, I performed
in all of those.
But that doesn't define me.
What defines me, honestly, is I
think my biggest achievement is
just every time I've been able
to touch someone's heart, that
has become my
biggest achievement.
Because what's the
point of going out--
like one of my dreams is to sing
in front of a billion people.
Yeah, a billion--
I mean, it's doable, right?
But what's the point of singing
in front of a billion people
if nobody's really
going to hear you?
If nobody's actually
going to listen.
So that's why I say
that it doesn't matter
about what I did as an artist.
What matters is who I
touched as an artist.
KIKO: Gotcha.
And it's also, obviously, you've
done a lot of covers of Eminem
and stuff like that.
But I guess my question is,
what artists inspire you,
just in general?
SPARSH SHAH: I mean,
there's a few actually.
Obviously, since I
came across Not Afraid,
Eminem was my favorite artist.
And he has such a
great lyrical genius.
I love that.
His story is great.
And I think, actually,
he was the one--
I had been exposed to
hip hop, I realized,
as I look back over
the years, more slowly
and slowly until I got to him.
But I always avoided
the mainstream industry,
because I thought, oh, man.
It's so bad.
All these people talking
about bad things and all that.
But I think Eminem was really
the rapper who showed me
that you could be
in the industry
and you don't have to
rap about that stuff.
Hip hop is not always bad.
It can be used for good.
It's not the devil's
music as they would say.
You can take a rhythm
and just rap over a beat
and you could make the
most inspirational message.
But I think like as I got
further and discovered
some other artists, I remember,
before I came to Eminem,
I used to listen MattyBRaps,
really awesome YouTube
sensation and rapper.
Few other rappers, they're
two rappers I'm huge fans of--
Minister, he's a gospel rapper.
And also Dee-1, he's
like a mix between gospel
and conscious rap.
My favorite part
about him is that he
doesn't let go of his
values and he will not bend.
Like he won't do something
that he knows is--
he won't sacrifice
something greater for, like,
one opportunity.
I love his motto.
It's called three's up.
So be real, be righteous,
and be relevant.
And I think every rapper
needs to live up to that,
because we're living
in an industry
right now that is barely real,
definitely not righteous,
and I mean, only a little
relevant, if anything.
So I want to be one of those
guys that really lives up
to that.
KIKO: And also, like you
know, you mentioned, I
think a lot of people have a
love for music very early on.
But I guess for you,
at what point did you
realize that this
was really going
to be a thing-- like,
something that was
very important in your life?
SPARSH SHAH: Yeah, ever
since I was little.
I've known it ever
And that was the great thing.
It was my dream
always to inspire.
So I wasn't following
another dream.
Like, I'm going to
make these records.
I'm going to do this money.
I'm going to get this money.
I'm going to buy this
stuff, get rich, and all.
I'm going to sing in live tours.
That was byproduct.
Really, the main
dream that I had
was to inspire
everyone in the world.
Singing in front
of a billion people
was just a vehicle to do that,
now that I look back on it.
And that's why I always say.
I want to sparsh
people's hearts.
Sparsh, my name actually
means touch, to touch.
So I just sparshed my left hand.
[LAUGHTER]
SPARSH SHAH: So in that way,
that's what I want to do.
I want to sparsh
people's hearts.
KIKO: In all the people that
you've touched and spoken with
and had an opportunity to meet,
was there a specific message
that you've gotten from anyone
that specifically touched you
through all your journeys?
SPARSH SHAH: Ooh.
That's a tough one.
Hm, a specific message, like, a
message that really struck me.
Ooh, man, you got me there.
I think honestly
the biggest messages
I'd ever gotten were
from my parents.
I mean, I got so much
encouragement from everyone
that I had met through
my performance journey
and everything.
But my mom and dad,
they were the ones
that really kept me grounded.
They showed me my purpose.
They showed me who I
really could be, who I was
and who I could be.
And so they always picked me up.
A lot of people
with disabilities,
I mean, now time's are changing.
But a lot of people
with disabilities,
they're not really
that recognized
because of their disability.
But that's what I like to say
I like to dis my disability.
Poof.
I dissed my disability.
[LAUGHTER]
That's the thing.
So my parents always
gave me that attitude.
If you can believe it,
you can achieve it.
And I really took that to heart.
And I think that's the
reason why I'm here today.
That message is
the reason why I'm
able to go out and sing in front
of 20,000 to 30,000 people.
And technically, I'm talking
in front of millions,
if not billions of
people, because this is
going to go out to the world.
KIKO: Yeah.
SPARSH SHAH: So without
that, without that attitude
and without that
outlook on life,
I definitely would not have
been able to come here so
boldly on stage and
be able to do that.
KIKO: Good.
And now, what is your
process for creating music?
SPARSH SHAH: Oh, wow.
Glad you asked.
So usually when I was
little, I used to--
yeah, when I was little and
I started writing songs,
the first song I wrote
was at the age of 10.
And it was "This Love
Will Never Fade."
And I didn't know
how to make music.
I was really bad at composing.
I still suck at the piano.
But I didn't know how
to make music like that.
And so I would try and
try, and it never worked.
But I would always
write down songs first.
I'd write down a song
first, and then I
would try, frustratingly, try
to come up with a piano tune.
And then time kept
going on, sometimes
I would find really
good beats online,
especially when I
started making rap songs.
And I fell in love with rap.
I listened to the beat,
make a song out of it.
And then I realized
that, you know,
I'd written so many songs.
And I tried going out to
people who could record me.
But everyone who I
knew was really busy.
So I said, you know what?
I have to do it on my own.
It was like a do or die thing,
because you got to move fast.
And so I was, like,
you know what?
I had to make my own music.
If nobody's going to do it
and make my music for me,
and nobody's going
to help record it,
I need to get the tools
that I need to do that.
I got a recording set
for Christmas one day.
I don't remember how
many years ago that was,
probably a few years ago.
And I got that done.
I started writing, and
I started making music.
So in fact, I have a MacBook.
I mean, I could
show you something.
KIKO: That'd be great.
SPARSH SHAH: OK.
Let's do this.
OK, so you all ready?
I'm going to teach you guys
how to make a simple beat.
You ready for this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
SPARSH SHAH: OK, so if you could
turn up this screen, please.
All right, here we are.
I'm using the cute little
Garage Band software.
I know everyone uses Logic
and Pro Tools and stuff.
I'll show you this track later.
But let's make a new project.
All right, now I'm going to
do this completely random, OK?
Ready?
You could yell out
anything you want.
I don't even mind.
All right, ready?
What key do you
want the song to be?
It could be, like,
I think it's from--
yeah, it's A to all
the way to G sharp.
What would do you want?
Yell out a number.
AUDIENCE: E flat.
SPARSH SHAH: Wait, what?
AUDIENCE: E flat?
SPARSH SHAH: E flat, OK.
E flat.
Station.
E flat, OK.
Major, minor?
AUDIENCE: Minor.
SPARSH SHAH: Minor.
Tempo?
AUDIENCE: 140.
SPARSH SHAH: 140.
OK, time signature?
Oh.
You know, I'll just
stick with the 4/4.
It's easier, you know?
I'm sticking with 4/4.
All right.
140, E flat.
Let's do this.
I'm going to try it.
So I'm not going to use
any audios or drummers.
I'm just going to do
software instruments.
So somebody just
give me a good--
is there anybody a
good beatboxer here?
You don't even have
to be that good.
All right.
Give me a beat.
Give me a beat, like--
AUDIENCE: [BEATS]
[LAUGHTER]
SPARSH SHAH: OK.
[MIMICS BEAT] OK.
I got this.
I got this, ready?
So what you're going
to do is you go, like--
I'm going to go to the old
GarageBand instruments.
Because I love to start
with that drum kit, hip hop.
Watch this, ready?
It's called musical typing.
It's so cool.
See, there's all these
different instruments.
Boom chee-- all right, so we're
going to start with that beat,
ready?
[PLAYS BEAT]
SPARSH SHAH: OK, so now all
I got to do is you go here,
you quantize the music
so that it's on beat.
OK, there it is.
So now what you can do is you
can layer extra stuff on this.
So it's really cool.
So this is the basic beat.
[PLAYS BEAT]
SPARSH SHAH: That's
the metronome.
Right?
So now watch?
Cool, right?
So like something like that.
And then you could
go to the piano.
[PIANO PLAYING]
SPARSH SHAH: So you
could record that.
It's really cool, because
then you can come up
with really cool tunes.
I want to show you some.
No, don't save.
[LAUGHTER]
SPARSH SHAH: OK, so this
is an instrumental I made.
It's really cool, ready?
[PLAYS RECORDING]
SPARSH SHAH: It's a
truck beat, by the way.
Anybody feeling the vibe?
I know you are.
Yeah, you're feeling it.
I can tell.
I made this, like, I just
came up with this idea
after finding out how
to use [INAUDIBLE]..
So I figured out
the chords and--
So that is just a snippet
of an instrumental.
And I just made this song--
no, don't save.
I'm always clicking don't save.
It's funny.
Now this is a song
that I just actually
composed like two days ago.
And I have the lyrics to it.
So you could even read that.
All right, ready?
It's like my intro song.
So like before I release
all my other songs,
this is, like, yo, world.
This is me.
So I came up with this
after some pretty hard work.
It took me a very
long time to make.
And this is basic.
I'm still learning
mixing and mastering,
and, like, that stuff.
I'm just really
piecing music together.
So this is what
I've come up with.
All right.
[PIANO PLAYING]
SPARSH SHAH: (SINGING)
[INAUDIBLE] No, I'm not a king.
My voice will still ring.
A prince with the power of pen.
So in the pages of
history written,
I will go forth and
down, dig my wheels
in the ground so not
even [INAUDIBLE]..
(SPEAKING) Yeah!
If everybody wants to
know the real artist,
the person behind the Eminem
covers, this is me, Purhythm.
(RAPPING) Now here I am
through all the struggle.
Clear my dance from
all the rubble.
Rose up from the
wounds that I took.
These got so much
boom, you'll be shook.
Move around faster than
the cast [INAUDIBLE]..
Read that book because
I'm right in my pages.
[INAUDIBLE] by the ghost.
Story's been written,
but I came with the most.
Move throughout the world
and the coast to coast.
Never go slow.
Yo, I may be learning,
not yet I'm great.
But I'm burning [INAUDIBLE]
(SPEAKING) Let me
try that again.
[CHEERING]
KIKO: Woo, how about
a round of applause?
SPARSH SHAH: It's going
to get better, ready?
(RAPPING) Yo, rap
flowing like water.
My [INAUDIBLE]
music is my fodder
'cause this is only inception.
Hip hop training succession.
I'm here to help
reclaim the lost
kingdom faded in regression.
[INAUDIBLE] to separate the wee
from [INAUDIBLE] I'ma stay bold
and I won't be scared.
But even in my life, I'm
remembering my prayers.
(SPEAKING) And that's
like part of it.
KIKO: Woo!
[APPLAUSE]
KIKO: Round of
applause, everyone.
Thank you for that.
SPARSH SHAH: Of course.
Oh, right.
I'm using this mic.
KIKO: I guess my question
is, obviously, you've done
a lot of creating for yourself.
Like, who is your dream to
obviously record-- you're
making tracks.
You're making beats.
Is it your dream to have
someone else, I guess,
record to your tracks as well?
And if so, who
would be your dream
to have someone record
to any of your tracks?
SPARSH SHAH: Ooh, honestly.
Yeah, I would definitely
love to work with others
to produce my tracks.
You know, I've never really had
any anybody in mind for that.
But you know, hey, if
anybody's out there,
and you're watching this.
I know, I mean, this
is Google, right?
Anything's possible.
So I don't know.
I'm free, if you guys want
some of my music to you know,
to produce some stuff,
I'm totally ready for it.
So yeah.
KIKO: What about artist wise,
to record to any of your tracks?
SPARSH SHAH: Artist
wise, artist wise, wow.
Definite-- I think ever
since "Not Afraid,"
it was definitely my dream
to perform with Eminem.
So I mean, that's
just performing.
But if we got to do
something studio wise.
That would be pretty cool, too.
I mean, I'm totally
ready for that.
KIKO: That would be dope.
So guys, we're going to play
a cool game, a memory game.
Could we get some volunteers?
I'm not going to say what it is.
Because I don't want to
scare you all off just yet.
But a memory game we're going
to play here with Sparsh.
Can we get some
volunteers, please?
We have two mics set up
at two sides of the room.
SPARSH SHAH: Come on, guys.
Don't need to be scared.
Oh, yeah, let's go.
KIKO: Thank you.
Thank you.
Could we get another volunteer?
SPARSH SHAH: Anyone
from this side?
KIKO: Anyone from this side?
SPARSH SHAH: Step up.
You don't have to be scared.
Don't worry.
KIKO: [LAUGHS] All right.
So the game that we are
going to play today.
So Sparsh is a master
at the numbers of pi.
He's memorized a significant--
way down the line.
I'm not even close.
So we're not going to even
talk about what I can do.
But we're going to play a
little game, and see if--
this is Google, right?
So we have a lot of
great minds in the room.
We're going to see if anybody
can go back and forth with him
with the numbers of pi that he
knows and that you guys know.
This should be fun.
So I guess, do you
want to start off?
Who wants to start off here?
AUDIENCE: 3.
KIKO: Huh?
[LAUGHS]
AUDIENCE: I'll start with 3.
I know that one.
[LAUGHTER]
SPARSH SHAH: All right.
Do you want to--
wait.
Do you-- can you--
I mean, do you have any more?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: 3.145?
SPARSH SHAH: Almost.
1-5.
Don't worry.
It's fine.
KIKO: You're not out.
SPARSH SHAH: You ready?
Try your best.
AUDIENCE: Question
is can I Google it?
[LAUGHTER]
SPARSH SHAH: I would
leave to Mr. Kiko.
KIKO: Listen.
However you want to
try to beat this man.
SPARSH SHAH: I would
say, you know what?
Let's try doing this.
You have the stuff on the wall.
Take like a few seconds to
memorize it as much as you can,
right?
And then we do like a face off.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SPARSH SHAH: Let me
know when you're ready.
You're ready?
AUDIENCE: I'm ready.
OK.
Let's do this.
AUDIENCE: OK.
3.14159265 and that's it.
SPARSH SHAH: OK.
Good job.
You ready?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
3.14159265-- you lose me there.
KIKO: Woo!
[APPLAUSE]
SPARSH SHAH: Good job.
KIKO: Nice.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Can you beat us?
KIKO: [LAUGHS]
SPARSH SHAH: Me?
All right.
This is my humble attempt.
[LAUGHTER]
No, no way.
Look, it's good, right?
It's all in good fun.
So that's the great thing.
All right.
3.1 4 1 5 9 2 6 5 3 5 8 9 7 9 3
2 3 8 4 6 2 6 4 3 3 8 2 2 7 9 5
0 2 8 8 4 1 9 7 1 6 9 3 9 9 3 7
5 1 0 5 8 2 0 9 7 4 9 4 4 52 30
78 16 40 62 86 20 89 98 62 80 34
82 53 42 117 06 79 82 14 808 65
13 28 23 06 64 70 93 84 46 09 55
05 82 23 172 53 59 40 81 28 48
11 17 450 28 41 02 70 19
38 52 110 55 59 64 46 22
94 89 54 93 03 81 96 44 28 81 09
75 66 59 33 44 61 28 47 564 82
33 78 67 83 16 52 71 20 19 09
145 64 48 56 69 23 460 34 86
104 54 32 664 82 13 39 36 07 26
02 49 14 12 73 72 45 87 00 66
06 31 55 88.
Um, that's all I got right now.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERING]
AUDIENCE: Woo!
SPARSH SHAH: Thanks, guys.
AUDIENCE: Amazing.
Thank you guys.
SPARSH SHAH: Yeah,
right, actually.
Wait up.
Might want to stay there.
I have awesome gifts for you.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
SPARSH SHAH: Yes.
For being such valiant
warriors in the pi game.
If you guys want to come on up?
[APPLAUSE]
KIKO: Woo.
Come on, guys.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPARSH SHAH: Of course.
Bada bing.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPARSH SHAH: Thank you.
KIKO: Now I wanted to
open it up for questions,
if any of you guys have
any questions for Sparsh.
SPARSH SHAH: Feel free to ask.
KIKO: Feel free.
Mics in both corners over here.
SPARSH SHAH: So nobody wants
to know anything else about me?
That is odd, especially
in a building of techno--
like, such great minds
all assembled here
in the world's
greatest technology.
OK!
There, we got somebody!
[CLAPPING]
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if you could just
talk a little bit about
how you use technology
and how that helps you.
You've demonstrated,
obviously, with music creation.
But I know, I mean, you have
a large YouTube following.
Just how do you interact with
computers, mobile devices,
those types of things to help
you with your daily activities?
SPARSH SHAH: Ooh.
That I would break
down into two things.
First one, two
words, social media.
The second one
would be education.
I mean, because now we've got
Google Classroom, Google Docs,
Google Drive, all this stuff.
And I don't know what you guys
are thinking about the Google
Drive, Classroom and stuff.
But we're using it.
It's great.
It's a really great platform.
We get to use it for keeping
our classes up to date,
and all that.
So for example, if I need
to look up an assignment
and my teacher has a
Google Classroom thing,
all I got to do is go on my
phone app and just click it.
It's so efficient the way
you guys have made it.
So first of all,
thanks for that.
And second of all,
the social media--
I mean, I've been pretty
active on social media.
I mean, Facebook, Instagram,
Twitter, Snapchat, and YouTube.
So it's, like, me
trying to build my base.
So that's a great thing.
And I'm able to use social
media to reach people
from all over the world.
So that's a great thing.
Because if I did not
have that ability,
right, like, if we were
back in the old days
and we didn't have
that kind of ability,
it would take
years for a message
to travel by sea
or boat or whatever
the case may have been,
even through telegrams
and telegraphs.
Now we have an ability to
send a text to someone right
across the world in one click
to live stream things, which
I know you, probably, guys are
specialized at because you guys
are like so awesome
with that field.
But you know, that's the
great thing about social media
and technology is that I get
to reach so much more people
than I really could have
if I was in the old days.
And that's why I feel like
my one billion people dream
is really realistic in my eyes.
Because I know I can do it
with the technology I have.
Thank you.
Oh, what's your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Mac.
SPARSH SHAH: Mac?
Mr. Mac?
Nice.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPARSH SHAH: And the other
awesome young lady who competed
with me in the pi game--
what was your name?
AUDIENCE: My name's Emery.
SPARSH SHAH: Miss Emery, nice.
Mr. Mac and Miss Emery.
OK.
I will do my best
to remember that.
[LAUGHTER]
KIKO: OK, we have
another question.
SPARSH SHAH: Oh, sure.
Yeah, I'm curious what
would you're like in school.
Are you in school now and
what subjects do you like?
And obviously,
you must be pretty
amazing at math and numbers.
And also, like,
what you're good at
and what you're interested in.
And how much time
you spend with music
and balance that with school?
SPARSH SHAH: Wow,
very good question.
Thank you.
Your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Jeremy.
SPARSH SHAH: Mr. Jeremy.
So I think I love music.
And even as a school
subject, my favorite class
would definitely be music.
Anything to do with that, even
if it's instrumental music.
Because it's, like,
oh, my god, it's crazy.
The connections, that music
has with us as human beings
and us as a core, in our core--
it's amazing.
Music can make someone vent.
It can make someone cry.
It can make someone laugh,
make someone smile--
all at the same time.
And that I think is
very, very powerful.
And in a way, all art is like
that, you know what I mean?
Every art tells a story
in a different form.
And the way I mostly balance
music and school, music
and school, I must say, it's
a very challenging task.
But the main way I
just try to do it
is taking one day
at a time, you know?
Take it a minute, day at a time.
Because then I can really
break it down and say, yo,
I don't have to
worry about tomorrow.
You keep in mind tomorrow,
but you don't worry about it.
And that really helps.
Because that takes
off a lot of stress
and when I'm going through the
motions of doing my homework
and stuff and trying
to finish it as fast as
I can so that I can
do my music stuff.
So yeah, I try my best to
spend as much time with music
as I can.
And sometimes it
may not work out.
But it's an everlasting
seesaw that I just got
to work out the right way to.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPARSH SHAH: Oh, did
you have something else?
Oh, OK.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Hi.
SPARSH SHAH: Hi.
AUDIENCE: My name's Kat.
I want to know what
inspires you to write music.
And maybe you can
also talk a little bit
about what your big
dream is of what impact
you want your music to have.
SPARSH SHAH: Wow,
that's a great one.
I think for me, music--
almost every song that
I've written in my life--
it's come from real
stories in my life.
Basically I tell people that
if you were to take my songs
and put them in the order, the
exact order they were written,
they spell the story of my life.
Because the way when I write--
that's like my venting place.
I can vent out the deepest
feelings that I have,
the emotions that I have,
and what I'm going through.
And so it becomes like a
chronicle of some sort.
When you look at the
songs and you're, like,
oh, this is what
Sparsh was going
through when he wrote this.
Oh, and now this is what
Sparsh is going through.
He moved on from this.
Now he's in something different.
And that's really what helped--
that's what I know.
That's how I get
inspired to write music.
And I think the biggest
effect I want my music to have
is just to inspire people
that, you know what?
No matter what
you're going through,
what obstacles you have,
if you can believe it,
you can achieve it.
Nothing's impossible.
Like I said in my Ted talk, if
I could turn impossible into I'm
possible, you could, too.
So yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, Sparsh,
thank you for being here.
It's a real pleasure
to have you here.
SPARSH SHAH: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: And for performing
for us and all that.
I do have a question
for you, which
is you're, like, a relentlessly
positive person which
is amazing.
You manage to find
positivity in so many things.
Do you ever get down?
What gets you down?
If you feel comfortable
sharing with us,
SPARSH SHAH: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: --sometimes,
like, as an artist,
does that ever inspire you?
Or do you find something
in your heart--
do you want to talk
about that ever?
SPARSH SHAH: Of course.
I definitely do.
Thank you for asking
that question.
And that's the
great thing about us
as human beings is that we may--
like this is the thing.
We look positive.
We always try to look
positive on the outside.
But we have to realize
that we have to let
people be vulnerable sometimes.
Because we all get down.
Simply put, we all
get down, right?
And usually, what
I told Miss Kat,
right, was that when
I'm writing songs often
it comes from very dark
and sad moments in my life.
As I'm going through
them, that's my vent.
Like, a lot of times I'm going
through situations where I
really wouldn't--
instead of talking
to someone about it,
I would write a song about it.
Because in that way, I
could express my feelings
to the world.
I could express my
feelings to myself,
and that's the ironic thing.
Because even though
I don't want to talk
to somebody at
the moment, I know
that I'm going to release
this and everyone's
going to hear it in the world.
But that's the great thing.
Because if there is even
one person out there
who says, oh, my god, that is
exactly what I'm going through.
Or I understand his pain.
I know where he's coming from.
Then that's all I ever
AUDIENCE: [SNEEZE].
SPARSH SHAH: --wanted
to do as an artist.
If I could--
God bless you-- if I could
change someone's life like that
and show them the positive
side of everything
that I went through,
and they know what
I've been through, that's it.
That's my ultimate goal.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPARSH SHAH: Of course.
KIKO: I think we have
one more question.
AUDIENCE: Hi Sparsh, thank
you very much for everything
you showed us today.
It was inspiring and
super cool as well.
I have a very simple
technical question.
So memorizing the
digits of pi so it
sounded like you were
actually approaching this
through music, as with
everything else in your life,
it's so core, as a filter.
So is that safe to assume,
that you basically memorized it
as a set of lyrics?
SPARSH SHAH: Yeah, I rapped pi.
That's literally what I did.
I rapped pi.
You hit the nail on the head.
So you know, that's the great
thing about mnemonic devices.
I learned pi through this
song "Pi" by Hard and Firm.
But they only had like
the first 191 digits.
And so after that I
needed to keep on going.
But then, I was,
like, you know, it's
like every bar has eight digits.
So for example, 3.1415926535897
93238462 643383279--
well, that was the odd one out.
But that's how I learned pi.
I kept on going with that.
So even after the
song ended, I just
kept on pretending that
the song was going on,
that it would infinitely loop.
And that way I just
kept thinking about it.
And then that's when I
realized I could use this
as a great and powerful tool.
Like, I could use
music to remember
all these things in my life.
So it was a pretty cool
experience learning it.
AUDIENCE: Pretty cool.
Thank you very much.
SPARSH SHAH: Your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm Balint.
SPARSH SHAH: Say that again?
AUDIENCE: Balint.
It's B-A-L-I-N-T.
SPARSH SHAH: Balint.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
OK.
I'm trying my best.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SPARSH SHAH: Of course.
KIKO: Thank you all
for your questions.
And I want to say thank you,
Sparsh, for being here today.
SPARSH SHAH: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]